the AP is running a story right now
about how the younger generation of
Republicans are down with the gays and
they are down with weed and they gave us
a couple examples a college Republican
group leader in Alabama was nearly
kicked out of the party for supporting
gay marriage so that means a leader was
down with gay marriage that's something
the successful push to legalize gay
marriage in Minnesota was backed by
several prominent younger Republicans in
Colorado the spokesman for a group that
pushed to legalize marijuana was a
Republican activist there's just a
couple antidotal things but there is
definitely a sense that on these social
issues mainly gay marriage and marijuana
that the Republicans are slowly coming
along this is good news am i right Jimmy
Dore well this is the way it's always
been right the Republicans the
Conservatives are always late to the
party so I don't understand how we still
give any of their ideas any credence
ever so they've been bitching about gays
forever and now they're gonna stop
slowly and so but their next thing and
then in marijuana so they're gonna stop
bitching about marijuana and then
they're gonna finally come around to
climate change when they're all
underwater and they're gonna come around
you know so it's just like what else are
you got of course you guys are wrong
you've been wrong about everything what
haven't you been wrong about you're
wrong about civil rights you mean you're
wrong about the EPA you're wrong about
[ __ ] every our energy policy you're
wrong about suppressing the vote what
aren't they wrong about so what you're a
young person what is it that's
attractive about the Republican Party in
those stories what's great is you're
right about every single one of those is
not one thing that they're right about
not one yet they still continue to
manage to convince young people that
they're better on the economy that
generic term of the economy when we know
full well that that not actually address
is not true either yeah so I don't you
know it's it's frustrating and when it
all a lot of what it gets to too is what
they'll never come around on is you know
suppressing the vote and civil rights
but it's just they still like it's great
a they're more open to black I mean the
more immigration right but but if the
people look different that they're still
they're still not on board but that's
but they're good that's gonna go away to
it after that lose again in 2016 they
will then become the party that's trying
to try and embrace Hispanics and and
immigrant they're gonna become that part
that matter at the end of the day if
they do it for principle or for desire
doesn't matter if they make things
better down the road but here's why I
don't think they'll do it because as
long as with what they if you think that
I'm being too harsh about race and that
they're plenty of young Republicans
aren't racist some of them don't know
yet like who they're in bed with right
real uh but where they'll never come
around where the part where they're
always gonna get resistance at the top
of the party is on wealth they don't
like poor people and they never will and
so when you when there's this thought
that Republicans after 2016 will come
around on immigration reform
those people need those people are still
poor and may in still need government
assistance they don't want any part of
that that is going to be a very tough
reconcile for them I think and in that
story by the way you see that like that
that that that in their list that you
gave that young Republican in Alabama
she was still nearly kicked out of the
party it was a woman uh but the head of
the Republican Party in Alabama was
still like you know that was very bad
you know he was like that we didn't like
that that was incongruous it didn't work
so I mean like those are anecdotal
stories and I mean they're moving it's
incremental they move the ball from the
half yard line to the three quarters of
the one yard line I mean they have 99
years collections moves them really
helps move them yeah does it I think we
could look at Jeb Bush I think if Jeb
Bush is the nominee that there's gonna
change the party on immigration for sure
forever well he loves immigrants now he
when his brother was a compassionate
conservative and I didn't he say a
couple ago he loves immigrants yes so
they said it's love now of course you
know and he has the he has the Colombian
part of his family his family's married
to call me they said the people who come
here he said that they're doing is moral
act or trying to help their family
they're being moral that's what you're
supposed to do they want to come here
and working off their family and we
should try to help them instead of
trying to [ __ ] on them so you're saying
that's a cold calculated political move
and not something he necessarily but I
think it's both but it's gonna require
money it's gonna record these people are
poor many of them are dirt poor and I
think that's gonna be a very tough sell
very tough sell for Republicans because
that is that is antithetical to who they
are helping other people yes we need
help they don't mind other people don't
don't write wait so getting back to to
weed in gay marriage oh so you guys
think this is just gonna be a
state-by-state thing for both of them or
is at any point the federal government
in a jump in well because they're
especially gay marriage I mean it's just
every week it's another one we've seen
it but yet look they're the the
eventually look realism will take over
and they're important issues are making
sure that the people who are gonna vote
for Democrats can't vote for Democrats
yes that's job one for them game yeah
like the Pope like there's a degree of
an you see some Republican attorneys
general around the country realizing I'm
not gonna fight us anymore this is a
silly thing this is a silly effort to be
fighting on on gay marriage like we're
gonna lose and it's done and certainly
as the Pope said hey look I'm I'm
against abortion and I'm anti gay
marriage but I'm in not interested yeah
I think what the Pope actually said was
if someone wants to invite me to a disco
party slam who might to condemn their
acts a good accident uh shouldn't the
Tea Party in the libertarians so the Ron
the Rand Paul's shouldn't they be for
legalization of weed and for gay
marriage if they were if they were Ron
Paul was they are well right right but
Rand Paul is not for gay marriage as far
as I know and he's really sort of been
weird about weed too
but he wants you to have individual
liberty and individual rights is in this
wheelhouse stuff if they were being
intellectually honest well yeah [ __ ]
up your whole point Rand Paul uh Rand
Paul is trying to play a delicate game
where he can be right-wing enough to get
the nomination and that you know for him
it'll be then a fairly easy track to the
center yet we know that Isis we put
presume about Rand Paul is care about
gay marriage he doesn't care about weak
those aren't that important to him right
being a republic what he doesn't want to
do is fall into the trap of being his
father who appeals to a bunch of kids in
college uh but when it really gets
serious that he's marginalized and Cena
he he needs to be seen as look at me I'm
enough establishment but I'm still have
this little cocoon carved out at the
very very hard for him so we're agreed
though in theory that already bleed um
that's gonna care where it's ultimately
get a play like that only a member he's
also a club become president yeah
but in theory they should be for gay
marriage legalization of weed right
Aryans they should be but is there a
libertarian that is should all should
also be right yet but where are those
guys well I mean economic I guess
conservatives do but social
conservatives shouldn't I mean so view
course they should know where they
shouldn't if they're being true to their
idea there's a biblical order establish
that the country needs to follow but the
conservatives correct me if I'm wrong
you know they're extrait
constructionists with the government
with the Constitution's so they would
say less government and you don't you
know doesn't say in the Constitution you
can regulate my marijuana or my marriage
so you don't get to do that I think
that's what a real conservative would
say the real conservative would say I'm
not for abortion but I'm for the
government staying out of it that's the
difference so they don't they don't
because there's a marriage of those
strict constructionists and religious
conservatives right that's the issue so
final thought on this which goes right
to that is abortion next for them after
these two things are sort of taken care
of is there any chance that they'll see
the tea leaves changing and and that the
huge numbers that some Mortimer's and
they'll just stop fighting it
they'll stops fighting something that is
I think it's something it's closer to
like 60% I don't think it's changing
more so we'll always stay the same
that's all we'll always be an issue for
them because the science doesn't move
forward it's always the same thing
either you think it's a baby or you
don't and so they can always tug at your
heartstrings and get you to feel that
way so that's why this won't change I
think but everything else is changing
the abortion is a much more
intellectually to get to it as a much
more intellectually honest argument yes
uh being anti-abortion if you believe
that I don't I think it's dangers to
women to not believe that but it is more
intellectually honest and nothing I
think juries right now I think those
numbers have basically stayed the same
and as we saw in that story Young
Republicans aren't actually moving on
abortion they are actually that that
they're still connected to those and I
do know that God is still an anti
abortion because if you have an abortion
and then have another kid he will make
it a downs baby